the quantitative easing will not lead to  the wishful increase of growth rates  because if we compare it to the u.s. we  have a lack of deregulation and  liberalization of labor markets and of  other markets and therefore our focus is  on the structural reforms which must be  done by countries like e to the in  France well this quantitive easing make  Europe more competitive it will it  create more investments and we haven't  seen any trace of that so far but it  will mean that it is livid too easy  maybe for furnishing some things instead  of doing the real things I'm very glad  that this step has been taken again by  mr. Draghi I think he had all the  reasons to take it he has a clear  mandate the inflation should be around  two percent the inflation is virtually  zero insert meant in certain member  states is even negative and so these  stimulus to the economy was absolutely  necessary